Okay, so we’re going to wrap up Freud today.
So Freud occupies a strange position in the
history of psychology, because Freud wasn’t
a psychologist, he was a medical doctor. And
many of the people whose theories we’re
discussing were clinicians, were MDs, not
psychologists. Well of course when Freud was
around, at least when he was training, psychology
hadn’t yet become an independent science.
Now the same was true of Jung, and part of
the consequence of that was that when the
new science of psychology developed into what
you’re studying today, the psychoanalysts
and the medical community basically stayed
outside of that. And there’s never really
been a meeting of the minds between experimental
psychologists and psychoanalysts. Although,
by the 1980s, the cognitive psychologists
were promoting their discovery of the cognitive
unconscious, which always felt to me a little
bit ungrateful, given that Freud had actually
laid the groundwork for the theory of the
unconscious and elaborated that in quite great
detail, you know, almost a hundred years before.
There’s some resistance (and that’s what
a psychoanalyst would say) among the experimental
psychology community to credit Freud with
any of his real discoveries, and I think that’s
very unfortunate, partly because a) he did
make the discoveries, and b) the psychoanalysts
still understand more about the nature of
the unconscious than modern experimental psychologists.
Because modern experimental psychologists
insist on viewing the brain as a cognitive
process, or something like a computer, and
that isn’t what it is. It’s a living system
composed of other living subsystems. And that
means that, as we’ve discussed already,
the human psyche and its subordinate components
are better conceived of as personalities and
sub-personalities than in any other manner,
than in systems or than in information processing
machines.
It’s… I think perhaps the most fundamental
accomplishment of psychoanalysis, following
Nietzsche, actually, to view the human mind,
the human psyche, as a place of relatively
integrated sub-personalities. I mean, even
when modern people talk about themselves,
they talk about the ‘I’ (which would roughly
be the ego, in Freudian terms), they tend
to think of themselves as a unitary phenomenon.
But the problem with that notion is that people
continually do things… they find themselves
doing things that in principle they don’t
want to do, or things that they’re ashamed
of, or lying when they don’t want to lie,
or generally misbehaving. And it’s also,
of course, everybody’s observation that
you can try to tell yourself what to do, but
that doesn’t work very well. So you know,
you’ve experienced this, undoubtedly in
your own life many, many times, when you’re
sitting down and you’re trying to study
for something, particularly if you’re not
very interested in it, then all sorts of alternative
possibilities will make themselves manifest
in the theater of your imagination. And in
a sense what’s happening in those situations
is that parts of you that are organised around
other goals or, from the Freudian perspective,
say, driven by other desires, are trying to
hijack control of your motor output. And that
frequently happens, so that you find yourself,
for example, procrastinating, or rationalising,
or displacing (those are all Freudian concepts).
A displacement would be, instead of doing
the work you’re supposed to do you go off
and do some other work. You know, it’s not
a bad way of procrastinating, but it’s not
great, because you’re not focusing on what
you should be focusing on. And so, in some
sense, you’re at war with yourself. And
the major player in the war, at least in principle,
is the ego, and that would be equivalent to
Freud’s conscious mind, at least in the
initial stages of his theory.
It’s somewhat complicated to talk about
Freud because of course his theory developed
across time, and in the beginning, he basically
broke the mind up into the conscious mind
and the unconscious mind. And you can think
of the conscious mind, well that’s you,
essentially, that’s the you that you can
refer to during day to day experience. And
then the unconscious mind is a storehouse
of two broad classes of phenomena. And one
would be drives that are grounded in instinct,
that are either at odds with your current
goal, or memories, often traumatic, that you
haven’t been able to integrate into your
conscious framework. And so those pesky things
take on their own life.
You know if you take an animal and you take
out increasingly large segments of its cortex,
say, the animal still organises itself into
that animal. Like it starts to lose function,
especially if you go deep into the brain (and
you can kill an animal if you go deep into
the brain), but if you stay on the cortical
surface, you can take an awful lot of brain
tissue out without interfering with a lot
of the animal’s ability to sustain itself.
And what that shows is that the brain is organised
in such a way so that isolated components
of it will take on a function of the entire
personality. And that’s demonstration, in
some sense, that the sub-elements of the psyche,
or perhaps sub-systems of the brain, can organise
themselves into functional living units. And
it stands to reason. I mean, if you lose an
arm you don’t stop functioning. You just
reorganise your personality minus the arm.
And if you have only managed to integrate
a certain subset of the potential psychic
manifestations of your mind, then that subset
is going to formulate the main personality,
but all the other things you’re ignoring
or can’t integrate, they’re going to have
a life of their own. They don’t just disappear.
And so, Freud offers the unsettling idea that
you’re by no means master in your own house.
And one of the ways you can determine that
is by watching yourself do things that you
don’t want to do. And those are things,
for example, that you’d have a hard time
facing up to, because of course most of the
things that you don’t want to do are things
that you might be ashamed of or anxious about.
And then of course there’s the defeat that
you suffer when your ego is hypothetically
in control of the circumstance and you find
your behaviour or your thoughts directed in
some direction under the control of something
that you think that you’ve mastered.
You can really see this in conditions like
anorexia. Especially if it’s accompanied
by bulimia, which it often is. So anorexia
is an eating disorder that causes people,
I think essentially, to become extremely disgusted
with their own physiology, with their own
physical being. And it warps their perceptions
terribly. So I had an anorexic client at one
point, and she was a rather small woman, maybe
5’2” or something like that. Quite thin,
obviously, she had anorexia. And I asked her
when she was in my office if her thigh was
bigger or smaller than mine. And she said
well it was about the same size. So I took
a piece of paper and I sat on it and I drew
the outline of my thigh on it, and then I
had her sit on the same piece of paper and
she drew the outline of her thigh. And of
course, there was probably that much space
on both sides between the two outlines. Well
she probably looked at that for fifteen minutes.
You know, she could not believe that that
could possibly be the case.
And I think what happens in anorexics is that
they stop being able to look at their whole
bodies. So when you look at yourself in the
mirror, you kind of have to look in a Gestalt
manner, you have to get a picture of the whole.
Alternatively you can focus on small parts,
but the more you focus on parts, the more
difficult it is to see the parts in relationship
to the whole. And anorexics get unbelievably
focused on small elements, and they confuse
themselves. So for example, if they’re looking
at their arms and there’s some flesh on
it, they are unable to make a distinction
between flesh and fat, and they want no fat,
they want to go right down to the bone. And
they can’t… because they’re concerned
about that tiny little part or maybe this
tiny little part, or wherever they happen
to be focusing, they get completely unable
to perceive their own bodies. And it’s quite
striking how far that can go.
And then the bulimic end of it is, well, the
person will starve themselves for a long period
of time, and of course, we’ll think about
this in modern physiological terms, feeding
behaviour is regulated by the hypothalamus,
and that’s an ancient brain region that
controls fundamental biological systems. And
it’s right above the spinal cord and it’s
a very, very, very powerful centre of control
in the brain. It’s functional enough, and
I think I told you this before, that if you
take a cat and you cut off its entire cortex,
and even most of its emotional systems, if
you leave it just with the hypothalamus and
spinal cord, which means it almost has no
brain, it can organise its behaviour almost
perfectly, as long as you keep it in a simple
environment.
So anyways, the anorexic attempts to starve
but… so that’s a conscious goal, you might
say, or an ego-related goal, or you could
even think about it as a goal that’s motivated
by other unconscious forces, because she doesn’t
know why she wants to starve, but in any case,
what generally happens is, she’ll run into
an emotionally upsetting situation. Now emotional
upset, it makes you anxious, or puts you in
emotional pain. That activates higher brain
centres than the hypothalamus, but they’re
still pretty low, they’re still pretty primordial.
And one of the things that kind of emotional
upset does (let’s call it stress) is shut
off your long-term planning. And the reason
for that is that if you’re stressed in the
immediate now, your body and brain presume
that you should devote… divert resources
from the hypothetical future to solving the
problem that’s right in front of you, and
that’s often a more behaviourally oriented
solution, like freezing or withdrawing, or
something like that. So it shuts off your
pre-frontal cortex.
Well as soon as that happens, then the hypothalamus,
which is, as I said, a very powerful system,
just reaches up in some sense and dominates
the person. I mean, it’s been there for
God only knows how long, you know, tens of
millions of years, and its job is to stop
you from starving to death. And you know,
you can imagine that over the course of evolutionary
history anybody who had a relatively weak
feeding instinct died. And so they weren’t
our ancestors. And so what happens to the
bulimic is, something will upset them, and
then they’ll get an uncontrollable desire
for often something that’s high-calorie
and sweet and full of fat, logically enough,
because they’re starving, and then they’ll
eat a whole quart of ice cream and two loaves
of bread.
And you know, they describe the state that
they’re in while they’re doing that as
dissociative. You know, it doesn’t feel
like them. Well you can imagine why, in some
sense. It partly is the whole realm of eating
behaviour. And eating is a sub-personality,
it’s not just a behaviour and it’s not
a drive. When you think about when you’re
hungry, it’s not like your brain is moving
you literally step by determined step. It’s
that you start fantasizing about food and
you start thinking about what you maybe want
and then you start to make plans about where
you’re going to go or how you’re going
to cook it and what social surround there’s
going to be and a whole bunch of things, and
that’s the hungry you. Well in an anorexic
or a bulimic, the hungry part of the person
is so dissociated from the ego part, that
they’re basically in a war. But one of the
problems with being in a war with your hypothalamus
is that it almost always wins. And it’s
a good thing, because otherwise you die. And
lots of anorexics do manage to starve themselves
to death.
And so that’s a good example of just exactly
how dissociable the mind can be. And the mind
is also… the brain is dissociable in the
strangest possible ways. So here’s an example.
I don’t remember the name of this syndrome,
it might pop into my mind. So you can have
a particular kind of stroke, and here’s
the effect of the stroke. You develop the
fixed delusion that a person who’s very
close to you (Capgras syndrome) has died or
been kidnapped, or somehow disappeared, and
has been replaced by their exact double. And
so it’s obviously something… it manifests
itself as something akin to psychosis. And
what happens is that the stroke damages the
relationship between, generally, the visual
systems that identify faces and the emotional
systems that tag the identified face with
familiar emotion. So basically what happens,
let’s say it happens to you and it’s your
mother… you look at your mother, but it
isn’t your mother. You know, your mother
comes with a whole complex of memories, and
you know, she’s set in a very broad context
of memory and emotion. And then you look at
this person, and it looks like your mother,
but none of that is happening. And so then
you develop this idea that well, if it’s
not my mother and looks exactly like my mother,
well then what could possibly be going on?
And the answer is well obviously she’s been
taken away and replaced by her exact duplicate.
People get into real trouble with this sort
of delusion, as you might imagine, because
they get obsessed with trying to solve the
problem: what did you do with my mother? And
you can understand why but here’s a weirder
thing, which is that it’s modality-specific.
So that if they listen to their mother on
the phone, that’s their mother. So you see
exactly how dissociable the brain is, the
mind is. Even down to small sub-functions.
So there are people with strokes who can sing
but who can’t talk. And there are people
who lose nouns and there are people who lose
only verbs. And there are people who can identify
things but they can’t name them. So the
idea that the brain is a dissociable entity
is obviously correct. And here’s another
example of it.
Well you dissociate all the time. Now if you
look at the way the brain is structured. So
there’s a strip right about here called
the motor strip. And if you’re doing brain
surgery and you touch someone with an electrode
on that strip they’ll move the corresponding
part of the body. And the hands are very,
very over-represented, and so is the face
and the lips and the tongue, for obvious reasons.
We fiddle around with the world a lot, we
move our arms and our hands a lot. The feet
are over-represented too. And then we communicate
about that with our face and our tongues.
So there’s huge representation there. And
if you touch that you get motion, or at least
the person will describe a strong impulse
to move. Well out of that grew the pre-frontal
cortex. And the best way to think… people
think about that as the substrate of abstract.
It’s not really a good way of thinking about
it, because you’re not really out to think.
You’re out to act. And the reason you think
is so that you can try out some actions in
a little world of fantasy before you implement
them in your behaviour. So to think things
through means to conjure up an abstracted
world and then to conjure up a representation
of yourself acting in that world to calculate
the consequences and then to decide whether
you’re going to implement it. Well that’s
another form of dissociability. Because you
could think without acting.
Now, you know, it’s certainly that part
of you that’s able to conjure up the alternative
worlds that human beings seem to particularly
identify with, you know. That part that’s
thinking… at least modern people really
think of the part that’s thinking as them,
or the part that’s capable of conjuring
up abstract ideas. And if it wasn’t dissociable
you’d just act out everything you thought.
Well that wouldn’t work very well. So the
brain is actually designed, in many ways,
so to speak, to be dissociable. So if you
understand that, and then you understand the
two sets of phenomena that are likely to be
dissociated, then you kind of got the essence
of Freudian theory. And the things that are
likely to be dissociated are 1) memories that
were traumatic, and I’ll talk about that
in a minute, and 2) impulses… they’re
not impulses, they’re not even drives, which
was the Freudian way of thinking about it,
they’re sub-personalities… troublesome
sub-personalities. And you can imagine that
those would be linked to complex positive
and negative emotions. One might be resentment,
guilt, shame, anger, anxiety, jealousy, rage,
lust, all of those emotions are difficult
to integrate into a personality properly,
partly because, in their pure manifestation,
they’re not… they disrupt the social order.
So like, think about how well regulated all
of you are sitting here. You think, well you’re…
it’s six million years since you diverged
from chimpanzees. If we took a bunch of chimpanzees
that knew each other as well as you know each
other, this place would be an absolute brutal
massacre. So, you know, for whatever reason,
you can control your primordial instincts,
that’s one way of looking at it, that’s
how Freud would look at it, you learn to control
them. And Freud’s theory, and this is where
it differs from the theories that we talked
about earlier, say with regards to Piaget,
Freud’s theory is really more about control.
He thought of all these potential sub-systems
and memories conflicting with each other.
Like a war. Like a Hobbesian war. So Hobbes
was the philosopher who said that life is
nasty, brutal, and short, and that in this
state of nature everyone is at war with everyone
else. And so you need a Leviathan, a top-down
control system, who will punish any deviance
from the social contract. Well that’s the
Freudian super-ego. Now Freud thought of the
unconscious and the conscious mind to begin
with, but later he dissociated that up into
id, ego, and super-ego. And then he thought
that each of those had their unconscious elements.
So you, if you’re under the grip of an id-related
sub-personality, let’s say, you could be
conscious of that, but there’s the possibility
for all sorts of other id-related sub-personalities
to emerge, so those would be in your unconscious.
And it’s also possible, and highly likely,
in fact, that the way that you’re perceiving
the world and the way you’re acting in it,
and even what you state as your goals are
influenced in ways that you don’t understand
by the action of these unconscious systems.
So for example, maybe some of you are headed
for medical school, and if I ask you why you’ll
give me six humanitarian reasons, but the
actual reason is because your grandmother
would be disappointed if you weren’t. And
she might not even be alive anymore, you know,
she may have… your mother may have imitated
your grandmother so that that ideal is firmly
embodied in her, and that set up the unspoken
expectations about your behaviour ever since
you were a tiny child.
So that’s an interesting sub-element of
psychodynamic theory too, and it’s really
something to watch for in your personal relationships.
It’s very, very frequently, if you watch
carefully, that you can see someone, especially
someone you love, because you have to know
them well, being taken over, in some sense,
by the spirit of one of their ancestors. And
I don’t mean this in a metaphysical way.
I mean that the thought… the personality
of the grandmother or the personality of the
mother has a structure that’s well-known
to the individual in question, and that individual
spent a lot of time imitating them in all
sorts of ways. And those imitated structures
can be passed down generation to generation.
I mean in fact, that’s partly what constitutes
your culture, right? It’s the imitated personality
of all of your ancestors that constitutes
your culture. And those things can possess.
Ideologies possess you in… not exactly the
same way, but in a similar way.
Okay, so you’ve got the id, and you’ve
got the ego and the super-ego. And, as in
the Hobbesian worldview, there’s real tension
between them, so that the id is always trying
to get its base gratifications, its base desires
gratified. Now, in Freudian times, that was
mostly problematic in relationship to sex.
And the reasons for that are quite clear.
There was no valid birth control, there was
very little employment option for women, so
their sexual behaviour had to be very, very
tightly regulated or they’d fall outside
of the social structure into prostitution,
or something like that, and then there was
the threat of various venereal diseases, most
particularly syphilis, which is as awful a
disease as you can imagine. It can imitate
or mimic all sorts of other diseases, and
it’s transmissible from mother to child.
So it’s a nasty one. So it was very difficult
for the Victorians to integrate sexuality,
because well, exactly how did you do that?
The one pathway to potential integration,
something the super-ego would approve of,
was a martial pathway. But you know, people
back then, back in the 1960s, people were
getting married around 19 or 20, but that’s
actually a historical anomaly. I mean, typically
speaking, in the Victorian age, a man usually
couldn’t afford to get married till he was
in his mid-to-late twenties, he just didn’t
have the resources. Women were married usually
younger than that.
But so there was a long period of time, for
men particularly, but also for women, where
the sexual drive, from a Freudian perspective,
was fully flourishing, fully manifesting itself,
but there was no socially approved mode of
expression. And so, under those conditions,
there’s a war between the id and the super-ego,
and the poor little ego is crushed in the
middle. Now you could certainly see that when
we were watching the movie, the Crumb brothers
movie, because they were basically in the
same situation. There was no socially approved
way that they could manifest any sexual or
any aggressive behaviour. And what happened
as a consequence was that both of those fundamental
sub-personalities, let’s call them, become
incredibly pathologised. Particularly characterised
by resentment and the desire for revenge.
Because remember these systems think… if
someone’s excruciatingly sexually frustrated,
let’s say, and let’s think about it in
the broader scheme of things, because sexuality
isn’t really… it’s not a narrow uni-dimensional
drive. You know, it’s associated with playfulness,
and it’s associated with the desire for
social contact, and the desire for communication,
and the desire for touch… like it’s a
complicated, multi-branching phenomenon. Well,
in the case of the people who we were watching
in the movie, none of that was either integrated
into their personalities, let’s say, or
permitted by society. And so it was bent and
warped and frustrated and then generated all
sorts of ideas about resentment and revenge
around it. So you can develop an incredibly
pathological sub-personality.
In the one cartoon if you remember, it was
the one that was most disturbing, where Mr.
Natural brought Robert that headless woman.
So he wanted pure gratification without responsibility.
So it’s a really id driven phenomenon. So
he had intercourse with her and immediately
after that was unbelievably guilty. And you
can see… so you think about what that must
mean. It’s like someone is under the grip
of one sub-personality, and it’s shaping
all of their thoughts and their memories and
their emotions. And all of a sudden that becomes
gratified, so it’s satiated, it disappears
and bang, up comes the other one. And in this
particular example it was guilt and shame
and anxiety, terror even, and self-loathing,
all of those things. And if you read about
the experiences of people who commit particularly
atrocious crimes, it’s very, very common
for them to experience exactly that. They’re
driven by sexual/aggressive impulses, because
those are the ones generally that culminate
in particularly atrocious individual crimes.
And then they’ll commit them and instantly
flip back into their normative personality,
except they’re absolutely terrified by what
they did. And you know, it’s… more than
one person is inhabiting the same psyche.
Now, they’re tied together by memory, generally
speaking, although Freud would say you can
also dissociate memory. And so Freud talked
about memories being repressed. And that’s
caused an awful lot of trouble, for a whole
variety of reasons. Because memory is not
the objective recording… it’s not the
objective unbiased recording of actually occurring
events. First of all because you can’t objectively
record certain kinds of events, like we talked
about this before. You can’t really objectively
record a discussion between a man and a woman
who’ve been married for 20 years about anything
important because for them, each word and
each phrase and each sentence and each facial
expression has to be interpreted within the
context of the entire relationship in order
for the meaning of the utterances to be extracted.
And there’s just no way you can record that
in a video. You’d have to have videoed the
entire relationship. And so you’re not going
to do that. And so memory is a very, very
peculiar thing, and the idea that you could
have an objective record is not a very sophisticated
idea.
Anyways, Freud idea, in some sense… he had
a somewhat… I hate to say… it was an insufficiently
sophisticated notion of what memory was. Now
I hate to say that, because Freud was a very
sophisticated person. But he did, in some
sense, believe in the existence of an objective
interpersonal world. And so he thought that
if something terrible happened to you when
you were a child, that you had a record of
the memory. It was there, as the memory, as
the event. And then you needed something that
would, like a censor that would repress that,
and then you needed a place for it to be repressed
into, which would be the unconscious. But
if you take apart a traumatic memory, generally
speaking, with someone… sorry, he [Freud]
also thought that repressed memory might be
represented in a symptom, a symbolic symptom.
So I think that the repression theory suffers
from the inadequacy of its representation
of memory, because here’s a different way
of thinking about it. It’s more in keeping
with the layer model, a hierarchical layer
model that we’ve been entertaining as we’ve
progressed.
So imagine that you’re molested by your
uncle, because it’s usually a family member,
when you’re four. Sexually molested. Okay,
the first thing you have to ask yourself is
just exactly what kind of memory do you have?
Imagine you’re completely sexually naïve,
which basically means you know nothing about
the sexual act, and its implications, or the
mechanics, but this happens to you. So the
first question is, how do you represent that?
Because to remember something you have to
represent it, that’s the thing. Because
you don’t just have a memory of the event.
It’s always interpretation, because there’s
so many things going on. Well so, maybe your
representation is pain and confusion, something
like that. And then there’d be another layer
over that, which would be the necessity for
secrecy. Because of course, the person who
does the molesting is going to tell you, well
one of two things, three maybe: it’s good
for you, you asked for it, don’t tell anyone
or they’ll think you’re a bad person,
this will be our little secret. Something
like that. So then there’s that whole overlay
of secrecy and inadmissibility, and what are
you supposed to do about that when you’re
four? How are you supposed to understand that
soemthign has just transpired that you’re
not allowed to share with anyone? You don’t
have a model of the world that’s sophisticated
enough to account for all that.
And so then perhaps from then on what you
do is avoid thinking about it. Now that’s
not the same thing as repression. Avoiding
thinking about something is not the same as
repression. Because it doesn’t require an
act of repress in order to do it. And then
maybe, you know, years later, you start to
recall what happened. But what you recall
is an unclear mess. And maybe most of it…
because you might say, well how are things
represented as memories when you can’t develop
a sophisticated representation? And what seems
to happen, and this is in a sense, the reverse
of Freudian theory, is that the event is represented
in the body. And so you can think about the
representation of event as a multilayered
neurological phenomenon. And so if you encounter
something that’s unexpected or frightening,
the first thing that happens is that very,
very ancient reflexive systems act first.
And those things are fast.
And so that’s the sort of thing that, for
example, might protect you against a snake
bite. If a snake jumped out at you you’re
going to jump backwards, and believe me, you
do that before you even see the snake. Because
it probably takes you a quarter of a second
to produce a complex visual representation
of the snake. And if you wait around for a
quarter of a second, then you’re dead. And
so what’s happened is that your nervous
system has conserved basic reflexes that are
only a few synapses long. And so maybe those
work between your retina and your spinal cord.
Your retina and maybe a very primordial emotional
system, like the amygdala, is wired up to
detect things like snakes and it just sends
a message down to your spinal cord, or slightly
more sophisticated motor control systems that
says “jump backwards now’. And then maybe,
you think about it, it isn’t even till after
that that your heart rate goes up and your
blood pressure goes up and you start to breathe
heavily, and then there’s a wave of fear
and revulsion, which is perhaps there to teach
you not to do such a stupid thing again. You
know, we don’t exactly know why you would
experience negative emotion, you know, or
what function a negative emotion has, except
that we do know that a pattern of neurological
behaviour that’s followed by a punishment,
or a threat, is less likely to be re-implemented
in the future.
Okay, so the reaction to the anomalous thing
is body, and then maybe it’s emotion, and
then maybe it’s image, like imagination,
you know, what just happened? And then maybe
it’s articulated speech. But lots of things
don’t get past image to articulated speech,
and some things, I think, don’t even get
past body. [Dr. Peterson’s phone rings]
Sorry about that. So I don’t think that
these traumatic memories are so much repressed,
as Freud had it, as never brought forward
for development.
So I’ll tell you a story about how this
might work, okay? So one time I had this client,
and she was 27, and I only saw her once. This
was when I was just training to be a psychotherapist.
And she came in to see me and she said that
she had been plagued by these thoughts of
being sexually abused when she was a child.
And I said, well, who was doing this to you?
And she said, well it was my brother. And
she said, he was a lot older than me. And
so I formulated this mental model of her being,
you know, somewhere between 10 and 13 and
her brother being somewhere between 15 and
20, because the way she described it was that
she was overpowered by a physically larger
male. So we talked for a while. And then she
finally told me… I said well how old were
you when this happened? And she said well
I was four. Okay, and then I said, well okay,
how old was your brother? And she said well
he was six. And so I said well look, you know,
here’s one way of looking at it. Like you’re
looking at it from the perspective of the
four-year-old. It’s a regression, in some
sense. That’s still how old you are as far
as experiencing the memory. Here’s an alternative
hypothesis. Your brother wasn’t a predator,
you were both terribly supervised children.
Well, you know, that made the lights go on
in her mind. Because she never thought about
it that way. Like she’d never taken that
representation, which would be her emotional
experience as a four-year-old related to a
six-year-old… a six-year-old is a lot bigger
and more powerful than a four-year-old, right?
It’s like 50% older, so it’s a big deal
when you’re four. But if the issue for the
memory is its relevance to current conceptualisation
and behaviour, it was much better for her
to update the memory, in a sense, and think,
well, yeah, like a six-year-old’s this high,
and a four-year-old’s this high, and what
the hell were my parents doing anyways? And
that’s an entirely different story than
the one that she had come in with.
And you know, that seemed to be a great relief
to her, and that’s partly because, you know,
if you’re bothered by a traumatic memory,
it keeps resurfacing on you, which it will,
and it’s actually one of the ways of identifying
a traumatic memory, it’s that the thing
won’t leave you alone. It’ll keep coming
up in dreams and when your mind is wandering,
it’ll keep coming up when your mind is wandering,
and maybe it’ll come up when you’re going
to sleep at night, like it invades your mind.
There’s a reason for that, and the reason
is is that the underlying emotional systems
that are associated with anxiety, so those
are mostly the hippocampus and amygdala duo,
in some sense, that are mediating those, they’re
an alarm system. And the alarm is something
that’s potentially dangerous has happened,
you need to figure out what it means so you
can stop that from happening in the future.
Okay so you need a plan. And to get a plan
you have to do a causal analysis of the relationship
between your behaviour and the traumatic outcome.
That would be the first thing. And then you
have to come up with a way that that won’t
happen again. And, of course, for my client,
that happened pretty much right away, because
now she was a 27-year-old woman and the probability
that she was going to be subject in any serious
way to a situation the same as the one she
was remembering was zero.
And I’ve seen this in other clients too,
is when they’re… okay, I had another client,
who, when she was, I think I told you about
her briefly, when she was young, four years
old, she jumped in a shopping cart and went
down a hill, like a paved hill, in the shopping
cart and spilled out at the bottom and hurt
herself. And they took her to the hospital.
And then, you know, she’s all primed for
being threatened. So that kind of means you’re
open to rewiring. And so then when she’s
in the hospital they don’t let her parents
come and see her for a couple of weeks. So
the trauma, the pain and the anxiety and the
threat and the ambulance ride and all those
things, which sort of puts her in a state
like this, which might be a, like a, state
that’s particularly conducive to learning,
because if something traumatic is happening,
you should be learning about that, what the
world’s like around that right now. And
she developed a permanent trauma-related paranoia
about institutions, which turned, by the time
met her, had turned into a whole philosophy
of institutional oppression. But its core
was that, and you know, rightly so, its core
was that combination of physiological trauma
and psychological trauma. And you know, mishandling
of the situation by people in authority.
So you can see under those circumstances how
a traumatic memory can become a core of a
whole large sub-personality, and that has
to be taken apart very carefully, especially
if that subpersonality isn’t the kind that
can be easily integrated into the world. So
for example, if you’re paranoid about all
institutions, you’re in real trouble, because
in a modern world, you’re faced with the
necessity of dealing with institutions all
the time. And if you’re more distrustful
and paranoid about them than you could be
if you were sophisticated, all that’s going
to happen is they’re going to continually
mistreat you. Because I mean if a dog comes
up to you and it’s looking suspiciously
and it’s barking and growling, you’re
not going to pet it. The way that you interact
with the system depends… the reaction of
a system to you is dependent, to a large degree,
on how you approach the system.
So anyways, the dissocaibility idea is a really
good one. I mean, if you want to get to know
yourself better, and this is sort of a combination
of Freudian and Jungian ideas, one of the
things to do is to… so imagine that you
have some sort of goal in mind. The first
question that you might ask yourself is, why
do you have that goal? What are the influences
on you that have set that goal up, because
it easily could be conscious or partially
conscious, or poorly explained, or implicit,
any of those things. So you want to know that,
why are you doing what you’re doing? And
the second thing is, if you find yourself
avoiding things on the way to that goal, the
next question is, why are you avoiding them?
And you know, that’ll mean delving into
parts of yourself that are quite hidden and
quite uncomfortable. So for example, if you
discover that the reason you’re pursuing
a particular goal is because it’s what your
parents want you to do, one question that
immediately arises is, yeah but is that what
you want to do?
And, you know, that’s a very complicated
question. Because you’d have to dissociate
the part of you that’s ‘the you that doesn’t
want to do it’ from the part of you that’s
‘the you that does want to do it’. And
then you’d have to figure out why in the
world you’d be avoiding. So you know, it
might be that you’re unbelievably angry
that you’ve been tilted towards this particular
goal for reasons that have nothing to do with
your choice, and so that every time you have
the opportunity to study, or accomplish something
that would move you farther to that goal,
you’re either not motivated, so you can’t
pay attention, you can’t study, you can’t
learn, and you procrastinate all the time,
or you do seriously counter-productive things.
So people for example, people can be… I
just had someone write me here a while ago,
because he was watching the YouTube lectures,
and he said that he had dreams for six weeks
that he drove his car off a cliff and crashed
it. And then, at the end of the dream series
he drove his car off the cliff and crashed
it. And he asked me what that meant. And I
said well, the dream is telling you that you’re
being far too careless with your life. I mean,
that’s what driving a car off a cliff repeatedly
means. It’s like, you know, that’s a good
descent, unconscious descent, into the underworld.
Well, and he was being warned, the psychological
reality was such that the warning was extremely
serious and so was the danger. And so then
you might say, well why would he drive himself
off a cliff? Well, you know, that’s a suicidal
gesture. And then you might ask, well why
would somebody be suicidal, and that could
be, well they’re out for revenge against
their parents, or they’re out for revenge
against the whole world, or they’re out
for revenge against themselves, or they just
want to make their painful consciousness go
away, or they’re living a messy and pointless
and painful life, and they want to punish
themselves for it. You know, it’s very,
very complicated and tangled down there at
the bottom of things, and people don’t really
like to look into it, and I suppose to some
degree that’s the shadow element. Because
what you find there is seldom what you want.
I mean one of the prime dictums of Jungian
psychotherapy, and most psychotherapies are
predicated on the idea that you should find
out what you’re avoiding and then you should
figure out how to voluntarily face it. Now,
you might add to that, you should find out
what you’re doing and why, and see if that’s
actually what you want to be doing. And if
those reasons are reasons you like. That might,
you know, in some sense sum up therapy in
a couple of phrases. But in order to manage
that, then you have to look at all the things
you’ve been avoiding. Well, what do you
avoid? Well, it isn’t rainbows and cookies,
right? The things that you avoid are the things
that no one wants to look at. And so, Jung’s
primary dictum for his psychotherapeutic practice
was a Latin phrase, which is ‘instercuilinis
invinoteur’ which I’m probably pronouncing
wrong, which means either ‘in filth it will
be found’, or ‘where you want most is
to be found where you least want to look’.
And you know those… that’s a horrible
philosophy. But you can see that it’s almost
self-fulfilling, because of course the things
you’re going to avoid are the things you
don’t want to face. Obviously.
Now, the shadow element of the psyche, in
some sense, when you were watching the movie,
for example, you saw these drives, mostly
sexual and aggressive, that were manifesting
themselves in all sorts of ways. And so that
would be maybe the repressed or unincorporated
elements of the id. But then there was another
more complex side of that, where the… people
were reacting to that, because they felt downtrodden
and oppressed and anti-social and critical
of social structure and all of that. Because
they were unable to manifest themselves properly
in the world. And that produced fantasies
of extreme destruction, exceptional destruction.
And for them they were mostly sexually related.
But for other people that can manifest itself
in incredibly violent fantasies about the
destruction of society as such. So if you
can’t invite all the parts of you out to
play, the parts that get left behind are not
very happy about it, and they don’t just
sit around having a tea party. They turn into,
especially as you mature, they turn into these
warped monsters. And their mode of action
in the world is anything but positive.
And a Freudian world… like the world of
the psychoanalytic unconscious, is quite a
terrifying place, because it makes you second-guess
everything. It’s like, it’s not a paranoia.
It’s very, very difficult, once you’re
trained psychoanalytically, to ever assume
that someone’s benevolent motivations are
only what they claim they are. You’re always
looking for the other missing piece. And I
think it’s extremely useful, you know, because
you run into people, particularly ideologues,
who will claim that they’re acting on the
world’s behalf. It’s like, yeah, who made
you a saint? And why should I believe all
the good is on your side? Like, what is it
that you’re not talking about? What is it
that you’re not revealing? I got something
from Greenpeace once, for example, that was
asking for donations. And the brochure was
just photographs of all the people who were
on the board. I thought, why do I want to
see photographs of all the people who are
on the board of Greenpeace? Or, the other
question is, why do they want to show them?
Well, you don’t have to think very hard
to figure that out. You know, it’s a status
manoeuver. What you’d expect in a mail-out
like that is “here’s six things that we’ve
done in the last six years that have improved
the planet, and here’s what we spent, in
relationship to administrative costs, and
here’s why it was a good idea”, not “here’s
our leaders”. Now there’s something wrong
there. And I mean, I picked Greenpeace because
it just happened to pop in mind but it’s
the case for all sorts of organisations.
Alright, so Freud, by 1900, had identified
a lot of different functions of the unconscious,
and so, here’s four of them. One was the
unconscious had a conservative function, which
meant that it stored memories, often inaccessible
to voluntary recall. Now we don’t really
know how memories are stored in the brain,
but here’s a guess. So when you have an
experience, imagine that that produces a pattern
of neural activity. It’s not just neural,
but a pattern of activity in your brain and
in your body. At least part of how you remember
is to reactivate that pattern, but it’s
not that simple obviously, because otherwise
you’d act out all your memories precisely,
and we don’t know exactly how that initial
pattern of experience gets edited down to
the thing you remember. But we do know that
it gets edited down in some ways as a consequence
of its relevance to your current goal structure.
How that happens? [shrugs] It seems computationally
impossible. We really don’t understand how
it happens at all. We don’t understand how
you can compute what’s relevant and what
isn’t. It seems that the world is too complex
for that to even be possible.
So conservative. Dissolutive. The unconscious
contains habits, once voluntary, now automatized,
and dissociated elements of the personality,
which may lead a parasitic existence. So I
talked a little bit about traumatic memories,
and how they might form the node of the development
of the sub-personality, but there’s something
else that’s worth understanding too. So
let’s say you start practising a new minor
mode of being, a new attitude, or a new personality
attribute, or a new habit, let’s say. It
can be a fairly small thing. When you first
start practising it, you’re not very good
at it. For those of you who are musicians,
when you first start to play a piece, you’re
very inefficient at it. And then the more
you practice it, the more efficient you get.
It’s very weird. I’m not a very good pianist
but I learned to play one really difficult
song. But the terrible thing is that I’ll
learn to play it, and then at some point I’ll
realise I don’t know the notes any more,
and as soon as I realise I don’t know the
notes, I can’t use those habit patterns
anymore. And then I have to figure out the
notes again, it’s very, very annoying.
But anyways, when you first start practicing
something, it’s effortful, it requires a
lot of brain activation, that’s what the
scanning studies show. But as you practice
it more and more, the amount of brain that
you use starts to shrink… it generally moves
left because the right hemisphere is more
involved in novelty processing. It generally
moves left and then it moves back, and the
area gets smaller and smaller and smaller,
until you’ve generated up a little machine.
Or it’s a little hard-wired sub-personality
that takes care of that particular operation.
Now that’s worth thinking about too, because
what that means in some sense is that your
brain is full of the things that you’ve
practised. And that’s not exactly psychological,
right, it’s psychophysiological. It’s
part of your psyche but it’s also hard-wired
into your brain. If you want to overcome one
of those habits you have to build a new machine
that shuts it off. You can’t just get rid
of it. And then what happens if you get stressed
often, that new machine will get… I don’t
know exactly how it happens. The stress will
reduce the functioning of the new machine
and the old habit will pop back up.
Some of you will have noticed this. How many
of you have moved away from home? Okay so
how many of you notice, when you go to your
family of origin, that all sorts of personality
traits that you thought you abandoned immediately
come flooding back. So you know that sensation,
right? You go back there and it’s like bam!
There’s a groove, and you’re right in
it. And you know, maybe you’re as mature
as a 30-year-old when you’re at your own
house but as soon as you come home, it’s
like poof! You’re fourteen again. And it’s
partly because of that expectancy situation
set up by your parents, but it’s also partly
because you just don’t understand how much
of your behaviour is automatic and cued by
ongoing events. It’s habitual. And so, those,
you might think of those as somewhat dissociated
elements of the personality as well.
Creative. The unconscious serves as the matrix
of new ideas. So that’s a more Jungian idea
and the way that seems to work… you might
think, how in the world can you come up with
a new idea? It doesn’t make sense, right?
Because what, are you conjuring something
out of nothing? Well, and you can say well
they’re combinations of old ideas, but that’s
not that helpful because you can’t just
take a bunch of old ideas and then shuffle
them and come up with some new, spectacular
ideas. It’s a lot more complicated than
that. So here’s one way to think about…
Freud investigated, in some sense, the surface
of the creative unconscious, and he was more
concerned about the… Jung called Freud’s
unconscious the personal unconscious. So that
might be the unconscious that you have that’s
related specifically to your experiences,
conscious and unconscious. Like it can be
deep. Jung had a dream once, for example,
(I hope I’ve got this right) that Freud
and him were excavating the basement of a
structure, and that Jung broke through and
found another huge structure underneath that.
And that’s just about exactly right. And
so there’s the personal unconscious and
then underneath that, in theory, there’s
what Jung called the ‘collective unconscious’.
And that would be, God only know what that
is. But in part what it would be is whatever
it is that makes you human from an evolutionary
perspective.
And we don’t know… like you have a specific
mode of being that’s a human mode of being.
I think it was E. O. Wilson, who’s a great
entomologist and also the originator of sociobiology,
which is like a branch of evolutionary psychology,
he studied ants forever, and social behaviour
of ants. And he once said if we could talk
to ants we wouldn’t have anything to say
to them. And what he meant by that is that,
like ants are interested in a bunch of things
that you don’t care about at all. Like they’re
not jealous, they don’t get jealous, they
don’t fall in love, they don’t have sexual
feelings or behaviours. They’re not a cognitive
creature. It’s like, what the hell are you
going to talk to an ant about? “How’s
it going, carrying that grain of sand?”
An ant doesn’t even care about that. And
so it’s interesting, it’s really a profound
observation, because what it indicates is
that you couldn’t even communicate with
someone unless you were 99% the same as they
are. Because to communicate with someone means
you have to share a whole massive immense
set of presuppositions. So for example, if
I say I got jealous at a party last week.
It’s like, you’re not going to say, what
do you mean, jealous? That isn’t going to
be your question. You’re going to say, well
what were the particular circumstances that
elicited that response? I don’t have to
explain anger, I don’t have to explain playfulness,
hunger… you know, all the basic human motivations
that you see displayed say, in the typical
adventure movie or romantic comedy. It’s
like, those don’t need explanation, because
we’re the same. And it’s that sameness
that constitutes the essence of the collective
unconscious.
Now, Jung’s hypothesis was that you’re
not only biologically structured, you know,
in terms of your morphology and your physiology,
but that that extends right up into your brain
structure and even above that, into the contents,
either the contents of your psyche, or at
least into the way that your psyche becomes
organised across time. And you know, it seems
like a hypothesis that’s so bloody obvious
that you can’t believe that people would
have disputed it for so long, but experimental
psychologists were very strongly influenced
by behaviourists. And the behaviourists assumed,
partly for ideological reasons, and partly
for the sake of scientific simplicity, that
human beings were blank slates, and that all
we were was what we learned.
Well, there’s a book out now called ‘Human
Universals’, unfortunately I can’t remember
the name of the author right now [Donald Brown]
but it’s a book, it’s a work of sociology/anthropology,
and this person has collected human commonalities,
so what’s the same about people everywhere.
Well, we pretty much all wear clothes, sometimes
for protective purposes, but if not, generally
at least for ceremonial purposes. There’s
pair-bonding in societies, people fall in
love. The basic emotions are the same. We
use fire, that’s a big deal, you know, because
no other animal can manage that. There’s
literally dozens and dozens of universal commonalities
across people, and that’s part of the substructure
of the collective unconscious.
So anyways, back to the creative idea. Well,
partly your creative act is going to be a
consequence of your attempts to integrate
the peculiarities of your own experience with
the peculiarities of your culture, and the
more general phenomena and states of being
that you share with other people. So because
you come into the world and have your own
viewpoint, you have access to information
that no other person has access to. And so
to some degree, that can be the basis of your
creativity, just that information. But then
in order to communicate it, which is also
part of being creative, right, because you
can’t just be… if you’re creative but
no one can understand you, it’s more like
you’re schizophrenic than you are creative.
You have loose associations and so forth but
you can’t put together a coherent story.
So then you have to take that unique information
and integrate it with your cultural knowledge,
your cultural narratives, and ground it in
universal human biology, and then you can
present that as a creative act.
Now, that’s one possible place for the origin
of new ideas, but here’s another. So remember
we talked about Piaget. And Piaget basically
said that to begin to understand something
you act it out. So you represent the world
with your body. By sitting on a chair you
represent the chair with your body. By walking
through a doorway you represent the doorway
through your body. By grabbing a glass you
do the same thing. So you’re matching…
you’re imitating the world all the time.
So you’re mapping it onto your physiological
structure. Okay, so that you get a sense,
that would mean, that’s kind of what understanding
means. You know, because that’s a complex
term to sort of understand. What does it mean
to understand something? It means to get a
grip on it. And you know, we use those terms
for a reason. You know, you’re standing
firmly in relationship to it. You can handle
it. All of those things.
So that’s one… so that’s the beginning,
but then also you’re capable of imitating,
so you can imitate yourself, which is what
you do when you repeat experiences that have
a positive outcome, but you can also imitate
other people. But then you think, okay, well
who are those people imitating? Well the answer
to that is, it’s like we’re LED screens,
and we’re constantly rippling imitations
of imitations of imitations of imitations
across our physiological landscape. I mean,
you guys are the sum total of a very long
evolutionary process, but you’re also the
sum total of an incredibly long process of
mimicry. And so, what you mimic is your culture.
So you could think of your culture as something
with a personality. It’s a complex personality.
And it’s the personality of your ancestors,
a perfectly reasonable way of looking at that.
And you imitate that. You know, that’s why
we call our laws a ‘body of laws’. And
you could say that the legal system, especially
with English common law, is the articulated
representation of the imitative customs and
rituals of the entire society. It’s been
brought right up into full articulation. But
it was there to begin with.
So part of where you draw your material for
creativity is that you observe the behaviours
and interactions of all people who’ve been
imitating all people since the beginning of
time. And that’s unbelievably informative.
It’s way more informative than you could
ever represent. You know how much information
someone can indicate with just lifting your
eyebrow a quarter of an inch, right? That
can indicate irony, that can indicate the
relationship of the joke to another set of
jokes that that person knows that you like,
and it’s very complicated. You can’t articulate
all that. But in some sense you know it, right,
you’re a player in that game. Well now and
then… so then imagine, okay, you’ve got
all that embodied, to the degree that you’re
a sophisticated player. Then your imagination
is representing you, and it’s representing
the world. So that’s an abstraction, right?
Because your imagination is not the world,
it’s a representation of the world. And
then what you can do… so that means in the
imagination, there’s all sorts of information
that’s about the imitated behaviour.
And then, then you can talk about the image.
That’s sort of what you do when you interpret
a dream. So what’s your dream doing? Your
imagination is watching you wander around
in the world. And you have your category systems
and your theories and so forth. And so then
your dream puts forth what that… like an
imagistic representation of what that might
signify. And it’s in this weird language,
which is an image-laden language. It can range
from completely incoherent, just juxtaposed
images, to unbelievable complex and sophisticated
full-developed narratives. And that’s part
of the process by which the information that’s
embedded in you and the culture at a behavioural
level moves up to the imagination and then
pops up into articulated space. So you have
a dream, the dream is about you. And then
you talk about the dream, and what you’re
doing. You’re trying to translate the images
into articulated representations. And that’s
also a good way of thinking about how memory
moves from the bottom up.
And what’s interesting… you know how sometimes
you have a realisation or a moment of insight?
And that… there’s a feeling that goes
along with that, it’s like a charge. And
I think it’s a charge that you get from
simplifying something but also from experiencing
the new possibilities that emerge as a consequence
of that realisation. What seems to happen
is that you have the behavioural realm, let’s
say, the things you act out, and all the things
you imitate, very, very, complex. And then
on top of that you have the image of that,
right? And you’re trying to get the image
right but it’s really hard because this
changes and this floats around. So you’re
trying to get those lined up, and then on
top of that you’re trying to get your articulated
representations lined up, so that you can
say about what you know about who you are.
And when all those come together, you think
man, I’ve got my act together. But now and
then you’ll have an insight, you know, you’ll
think… well, like this women who I told
you about who had been molested. The insight
was well, I was a little kid but so was my
brother. Bang! It’s like, wow, all sorts
of things that didn’t make sense anymore
just fall into place. You get this articulated
representation that can sum up a whole bunch
of… what would you call them? Divergent
and apparently unrelated image representations.
And then all of a sudden your path forward
is clearer. Because you know more about who
you are and you know more about how you…
where you’re going.
And that is in large part what’s happening
in psychoanalysis. It’s certainly something
that happens in dream analysis, which is something
that Freud also pioneered. You know, Freud
believed that dreams were wish fulfillments.
And, you know, he believed that the function
of dreams about wish fulfillments were to
protect sleep. So for example, maybe you’re
really thirsty, and you go to sleep. And you
dream about drinking water. Some of you who
have consumed too much beer the night before
might be familiar with those sorts of dreams.
And so you’re dreaming that you’re searching
out fountains and you’re drinking, and Freud’s
interpretation of that would be, well, you
should stay asleep. And so the dream is providing
your underlying id-related motivational system,
say the one that governs thirst, with the
fulfillment of its desire. But I think that’s…
I really think that’s wrong, although it’s
weird because dreams of course could be doing
all sorts of things. But what seems to happen
instead… I realised this most particularly
once I heard about a study about the effects
of testosterone, cycling testosterone on female
sexual activity.
So the plan is this, is that in women testosterone
levels vary across the monthly cycle, and
so does sexual desire. And what seems to happen
is that as testosterone increases, the frequency
of sexual acts doesn’t necessarily increase,
but the frequency of sexual fantasy increases.
And so the hormone is driving the fantasies,
and then the fantasies drive the behaviour,
it’s something like that. And so, the dream
isn’t fulfilling a wish, what it’s doing
is… that’s how the motivational system
manifests itself in a plan for action. It’s
like well you should be going to look for
sources of water, if you’re thirsty. And
so, because the… you know the hypothalamus
has to communicate with you somehow. It doesn’t
just grip your behaviour and move you around
like a robot. You know, it has to indicate
what the state, what your state is, it does
that all sorts of ways, and then start tilting
you towards solutions, using your memories
and your skills and everything that would
be related to successful outcomes of that
form in the past.
The other thing I should say about creativity,
and this is I think something very useful
for understanding people’s reactions to
psychoanalysis. I have a lot of creative people
in my clientele, for a variety of reasons,
and some who aren’t creative. And creativity
is a trait. And most people aren’t creative.
It’s not common. And some people who are
creative are so creative it’s just absolutely
beyond comprehension. So Picasso for example,
created 65,000 works of art, three a day for
65 years. Now that guy was creative. So anyways,
lots of people aren’t creative, and they’re
not interested in psychoanalytic ideas, they’re
not interested in archetypal ideas, they’re
not really gripped by narrative. So if you
happen to be… one marker for creativity
by the way, for openness, is really liking
fiction. And women actually like fiction more
than men, because women are actually slightly
higher in part of openness than men are.
So what else… if you like poetry, you know,
and it gives you an aesthetic experience,
if you really get deeply involved in music,
if you’re able to produce things that are
creative. If you have the kind of mind that
works in associations. So for example, if
I told you guys alright, write down as many
words as you can in the next three minutes
that begin with the letter L. Those of you
who are more creative would come up with more
words. So there’s a verbal fluency component.
I could say, okay, how many uses can you think
of for a brick? And then I would score that.
The first would be how many uses you came
up with, that would be the sheer number, I’d
throw away the stupid ones that make no sense,
and often you have to get a panel of people
to make that judgment, right. You know, you
could say “well, you could use it as a thing”.
It’s like no, X, you don’t get a score
for that. So then, you get another score for
how uncommon your response was. And that’s
an originality dimension. And actually if
you calculate those two dimensions, fluency
and originality, from a divergent thinking
task, which is the one I just told you about,
you can predict how creative people are quite
well.
Anyways, the really creative people seem to
have a deep well-spring of unconscious ideas
that are always flowing forth, and some of
those people dream like mad. And they have
extremely sophisticated and complex dreams,
and those dreams seem to guide their behaviour.
And that’s quite entertaining when you see
that in psychotherapy if you have an interest
in such things. And you might say well, how
do you know if your dream interpretation is
true? And the answer to that is, well how
do you know if how you interpreted the last
book you read is true? And the answer to that
is, you don’t, and even if you did, you
don’t know how you know it. Because lots
of people can read a book and they come away
with slightly different interpretations of
it. And that’s because, you can imagine
that the book is a multi-level pattern. And
then the reader is a multi-level pattern.
And then if you put those two together, you
get a multi-level pattern that’s made out
of the reader and the book, and that’s going
to be unique for every single reader. Except
that we have commonalities of structure so
that we can communicate about it.
So you read a book and it strikes you, certain
things strike you and certain things seem
right. If you do a dream interpretation, it’s
a collaboration between you and the client
about the interpretation. So usually what
I do is I have people, first of all they’ll
tell me their dream, from beginning to end.
Now Freud would say, already you’re introducing
all sorts of bias, because they’re not telling
you the dream, they’re telling you the dream
as they interpret and remember it. It’s
like yeah, that’s a problem. But you do
what you can, you know? And I tell people
just write it down as fast you can and try
not to think about it too much, because we
don’t want post-dream editing. And so then
I’ll listen to it, and then they’ll tell
it to me again, slowly. And then I’ll listen
to a sentence and then I’ll let my associational
network work on it, and then see what that
reminds me of, and then I’ll ask the person
what it reminds them of. And then we’ll
talk about… those are the direct associations,
those are the things Freud would call ‘free
associations’. And you could say, well,
around every utterance, like a sentence, there’s
a collection of potential meanings, right?
And those meanings might be direct meanings,
like really tightly associated with it, to
sort of loose meanings. And so you can hit
back and forth with client and therapist,
until you think, oh yeah, okay, that seems
to be where that’s going. And you’re also
thinking about it in relationship to the person’s
current life experiences and the rest of the
dream and maybe all the dreams they told you
about before. So it’s insanely complicated.
But it’s what people do when they listen
to a conversation. You know, how do you know
you’re interpretation of a conversation
is true? Well, you know, there’s a variety
of ways that you can approximate that, but
you don’t know. And there’s lots of different
ways of interpreting a conversation. That’s
why the post-modernists ended up in their
little hole with regards to literature. They
realised that there’s no limit to the number
of ways you can interpret a book. But then
they took the next step which was that therefore
it has no meaning. It’s like no no no, wrong,
wrong. It’s very unsophisticated thinking.
It just means that the way the book portrays
meaning is exceedingly complex, and you can’t
describe it using normal, linear rationality.
It doesn’t mean the meaning isn’t there.
That’s so pathetic. That’s such a pathetic
theory. It’s dangerous too because it means
that nothing has any meaning and that’s
the most dangerous theory, that.
So anyways, you talk to the person about the
dream and the dream image and about what that
triggers off in their memory, and you also
watch what they say, because sometimes…
so for example, someone (this just happened
recently) might be describing a dream where
they, where they’re wandering around somewhere,
and they’ll say “and I’m taking the
wrong road”. You think oh, okay! Well now
we know what your dream meant because you
just said it. I’m taking the wrong road.
And that’s a Freudian slip, and it’s so
interesting, because if you listen to people
tell their dreams, you have to kind of listen…
it’s like they have two minds talking at
the same time. And one is describing the dream,
but the other one is describing their life,
and they don’t even notice the connection,
and you point it out and they go oh yeah!
Right, right I didn’t know I said that.
And that’s a Freudian slip. And I think
what’s happening, in part, is the right
hemisphere, which is an image accumulation
and aggregation system, it’s kind of a low-resolution
pattern collection system, uses mostly images.
And tries to put them together in meaningful
ways, but the meaning is vague and comprehensive.
And then the left hemisphere, roughly speaking,
which is the linguistic hemisphere, is trying
to state what that says in words. And it’s
very difficult to make that transformation,
but that’s why dream analysis works in part.
It’s because you’re facilitating the movement
of the information in the images into the
articulated part of the personality. You’re
moving information up the abstraction hierarchy
to the point where it can be well utilised.
Now, I’ll end this with… I’ll end this
discussion of Freud with a description of
some research that was done recently by…
relatively recently, let’s say the last
20 years, by this psychologist at the University
of Texas at Austin, whose name is James Pennebaker.
And Pennebaker is a particularly smart psychologist.
And he had this idea… Freud had another
idea that was related to therapy, and he thought
that what happened, if you came into therapy
and you talked about a traumatic event, was
that you were cured by catharsis, which meant
that the trauma had a bunch of emotion associated
with it, and that was repressed but it was
down there kind of struggling to get out,
and causing you all sorts of stress and misery
trying to hold it down. And then if you could
just tell someone about it, and express your
feelings, then that would help you. Expressing
your feelings does not help you, by the way.
That turns out to be wrong, but it turns out
to be wrong in an interesting and useful way.
Because it’s sort of… it’s almost right.
So what Pennebaker did was he took undergraduates
and he had them come in to the lab for three
consequential days, and he had them write
for fifteen minutes each day about the worst
thing that they had ever done or the worst
thing that had ever happened to them. Often
people are traumatised by something they did,
not something that happened to them. In fact,
more often, because someone watches themselves
do something absolutely horrific, and then
they think, ‘oh my God! I did that! Who
am I?” They don’t know, and then that’s…
you know, things start coming unglued.
So anyways, Pennebaker had them do that, and
then for the next two weeks they felt pretty
wretched about it. And so, that’s interesting,
because if they would have only measured the
result of the intervention in the two week
time-span, everyone would have said never
write down your traumatic experiences because
it’ll make you worse. But over the next
six months, what happened in particular was
that their physical health improved. They
went to the doctor less, they reported less
illness, and so forth. And it’s because
their overall level of stress decreased, for
complex reasons that we could talk about later.
But then Pennebaker, being an excellent scientist,
he thought okay, well catharsis works, you’re
expressing your trauma and poof! You’re
fixed. But he went back and he thought, well
wait a second. Maybe how you express it matters.
So he went back and he counted all the words
that were associated with emotion, and all
the words that were associated with understanding
and cognition. And what he found was two things:
one was the more words that you use, particularly
as your narrative developed, that indicated
comprehension and understanding, the better
you did over time.
And so what happens is, it’s not the expressing
of your emotion, it’s the expressing of
your emotion and then the weaving of the memory
into a new coherent representation from which
you derive a moral. So what’s the moral
of a trauma? Don’t let it happen again.
That’s the moral. And the threat systems
are going to be throwing that thing up at
you constantly until you figure it out. How
did I get into this, how do I avoid it in
the future? That doesn’t mean it’s your
fault, but your anxiety systems, they don’t
care about that. They care about how you’re
not going to fall into the same hole. And
the only way to do that is to analyse the
causal pathways that led to the hole to begin
with, and see if you can either reconfigure
your behaviour and your attitude, so that
doesn’t happen again, or maybe you just
don’t go those places anymore. Either way.
And your… the trauma threat systems, as
soon as you come up with a comprehensive representation
that you believe in, they’ll leave you alone.
And this can happen very, very rapidly. Like
with nightmares, I’ve cured people’s nightmares
in one session, no problem.
I ask them to bring the nightmare up into
their imagination. Maybe someone’s chasing
them. Okay, think about them chasing you.
You’ve got to visualise it, really visualise
it. The more real you make it, the better.
Okay, they’re being chased. How are you
feeling? “I’m all anxious and afraid”.
Okay, turn around and look at the thing that’s
chasing you. So they do that. Then maybe they
say what it is or whatever, but maybe they
don’t even do that. And then I say okay,
before you go to bed at night, just when you’re
almost falling to sleep, you’re in a hypnogogic
state, where images are starting to come,
you run that. So they run that, poof! That
nightmare’s gone. And the reason for it
is that they’ve now reconfigured themselves
as the thing, not the thing that’s being
chased, that’s a prey animal, they’ve
configured themselves as the thing that can
turn around and face the thing that’s chasing
them. And that’s the same motif as the dragon
hunt in the Jungian archetypes, right? Face
what you’re afraid of and that will cure
you. And that’s really one of the fundamental
motifs of Freudian psychoanalysis.
So, you know you have an exam on Thursday.
I’ll post representative questions of the
exam when I get home after this lecture, probably
this evening. The test is here, it’s multiple
choice, you’ll have no problem finishing
it, it’s not that long. And if you’ve
done the readings and come to the lectures,
you’ll probably do fine. It’s not a tricky
test.